Speaker 1: Marjorie Taylor GREENE, the radical
Republican congresswoman, famously went into
New York City yesterday with a protest.
The protest was going to be at noon in support
of Trump, and then it was moved up to 10:30
a.m.
It was obviously not going to go very well.
And I'm going to show you a couple of clips
of this.
But Marjorie Taylor GREENE ended up having
to flee her own protest as hecklers completely
shut the entire thing down.
Here is Marjorie Taylor GREENE with a megaphone
trying to speak to the crowd.
And yet there are so many people with whistles
that you can't hear a damn word she's saying.
It's just it's delightful.
And remember, guys, this is speech.
This is everyone's speech.
She is it.
She has a megaphone and people have whistles.
And it's speech versus speech.
And the mayor at a rally.
Unidentified: Check it out by name.
Are you allowed I mean.
Speaker 6: You're straight out down here.
Oh.
Speaker 1: By the way, there appear to be
more members of the media there than actual
people protesting in support of Trump.
Speaker 4: Loud noise in the morning.
Unidentified: The police officers are doing
their job.
Speaker 4: I like them.
Speaker 1: All right.
So you get it.
Just nobody can hear what she's saying and
it's just all pathetic.
Now, at another point, I am told that actor
Michael Rapaport, who hates Trump.
That this is him yelling at Marjorie Taylor.
GREENE And there is some some language in
this clip.
I believe that this is indeed Michael Rapaport
there and just dressing down Marjorie Taylor.
GREENE Listen to this.
Unidentified: You know, you go back to.
Speaker 4: You left the sanctuary, you saw
the animal chewing on his face.
Speaker 1: And I hit him with the space laser.
And this is as NYPD is like, trying to clear
a path for Marjorie Taylor.
GREENE And again, it's mostly reporters.
Like most of the people, there are reporters
plus Michael Rapaport screaming at her.
Speaker 4: You lost your race.
It will be infected animal.
You got to get him.
Speaker 1: Okay.
So a lot of screaming at this event as Marjorie
Taylor GREENE had to be rushed out by, I guess,
security and NYPD.
A Democratic congressman, Jamaal Bowman, He
was not amused by Marjorie Taylor Green's
presence there.
Speaker 4: Do you think, in Georgia, Marjorie
Taylor GREENE he'll need to be in New York
City talking that nonsense.
Go back to your district.
What are you doing here?
You're here for politics.
You're here because you want to be V.P.
You're here for your own fundraising.
You're here for your own nonsense.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
So Jamaal Bowman accurately pointing out what
this is all about.
And then lastly, this is really weird.
When Marjorie Taylor GREENE was able to flee
to her car, she did an interview with Steve
Bannon, who refers to her as colleague, as
congressman, for for some reason I can't really
figure out.
And she claims that Eric Adams, the mayor
of New York City, organized a counter-protest
against her.
Check this out.
Speaker 3: Congressman GREENE The.
Speaker 1: Congressman.
GREENE It apropos of nothing, Steve Bannon
refers to Marjorie Taylor GREENE as congressman
from the gender realists.
Very surprising thing to hear.
Speaker 3: Congressman GREENE, the mayor of
New York, Eric Adams, specifically singled
you out as a hooligan that's going to cause.
Speaker 2: A problem and that you're dangerous,
and yet you've got to back off and go home.
Your thoughts, ma'am?
Speaker 6: He didn't just single me out, Steve.
He threatened me, called me by name, and threatened
me.
The mayor of New York City, I believe, is
a thug.
And he sent his people here today.
They had an organized text alert that went
out calling what I would say, Antifa to bring
their whistles, pots and pans, all kinds of
instruments to make.
Speaker 1: They brought pots and pans and
they almost started making a souffle.
Speaker 6: All kinds of noise to drown me
out and drown.
Others here today that are protesting in here
supporting President Trump.
The mayor of New York City, Mayor Adams, owes
me an apology.
I'm an elected member of Congress.
I represent hundreds of thousands of people
from northwest Georgia, but I also represent
Americans all over the country that support
anyway.
Speaker 1: You know, the really funny thing
was the guy handing out the whistles was actually
reported to be a Trump supporter.
So like the idea that it was the left that
organized the whistle protest, I guess a Trump
supporter thought that by handing out whistles,
they would be able to drown out the anti-Trump
protesters across the street.
But all it actually did was drown out Marjorie
Taylor GREENE And I'm sure some anti-Trump
people gladly accepted whistles as well.
So complete and total chaos on the streets
of New York City.
And I agree with Jamaal Bowman.
Why is Marjorie Taylor GREENE even there?
She has nothing to do with New York City.
She says New York City is a terrible place.
She says that, you know, we've got all this
crime in New York City and so on.
And so why why bother Marjorie?
Just stay home or go somewhere else, or go
to Mar a Lago where she did ultimately end
up later yesterday evening.
So that was the the big protest organized
by Marjorie Taylor GREENE.
We'll take a quick break and be back with
so much more